so the reason I wanted to do this
podcast is twofold
60% of the reason who I wanted to do it
was because I was on the violent on
season one and the filming and editing
process is interesting and I know it's a
very popular TV program I think that
fans of the show would like to find out
some of the stuff that goes on during
the process 40% of the reason is due to
a pure time management perspective that
I get asked the same questions over and
over and now all that I need to do is
link them to this single podcast so even
ten minutes ago you got a text saying
what was the violent like I'm eight what
was it like on the violent so now all
that I mean short cut on Alfred or on
text correction on my phone life hacks
one life hacks one that camera why don't
that one fellows not looking at me man I
see very well if you are listening
through iTunes we are in a room
surrounded by technology mmm but it's
been offset by the fact that I've got
some lovely candles over the far side
yeah a technology was too much yeah
exactly
so did I'd review watch the violin when
I went on I'm talking to people who
don't want one about the violent is a
reality TV program in the UK it is a
little bit like a cross between taking
out and Big Brother I think it's
probably pretty fair to say it's not as
sort of cheesy or Ron sheep as X on the
beach which is an MTV show or as Geordie
Shore it's not kind of as extreme as
that it's kind of look it's quite fluffy
in a way I guess and yet I was on the I
was the first person through the door on
season 1 and I was there for three weeks
three in a bit weeks I was there and
yeah it was
whose three no two and a half years ago
now but it has just been released on
Netflix we've had another surge of dress
I mean the people they've been ruling me
about stuff that I did two and a half
years ago when I can't remember what I
did this morning
so I guess the first thing is have you
re watched it or we've watched any part
of it to refresh your memory or when
people just referred yourself around
Johnny it's fine
so what's happening is I'm trying to
find a comfortable place to sit and my
bleep need keeps krumping why's that
because my legs are so long no it's not
because he didn't do wrong more toilet
well yeah okay so life hacks one life
hack for life I was one on one so what
was your question
Oh has there been more so have you
watched anything to refresh your
memories or when people ask you about
specifics is that like oh yeah I did
that thing if I'm honest my memory of
what happened now is almost exclusively
from the TV viewers perspective right so
my memories of being but know there'll
be an exaggeration it's 50/50 50% of my
memories are watching it from the angle
of the camera so when you when you see
it can you think like I remember to a to
a degree but I suppose you're only
seeing a very you seeing a very filtered
version of what actually happened don't
you but even though I like it obviously
I was there but it's just there's just
something strange about watching
yourself on TV
really really weird especially because
it is edited quite nicely and stuff like
that but yeah so that's a I think the
there's one question that everyone asks
it's the first question that everybody
asks about the violent and it is it
scripted and it's not at all
I think surprises a lot of people zero
structure okay so okay what they say is
is it scripted and I think a lot of the
reasons for that are when you take a
normal conversation normal discourse
day-to-day and you put like a Justin
Bieber song in the background and like
have a drone flying around or like some
cool music and a camera floats around on
the boom are when you chop it up
cleverly you the whole point is to make
it seem cohesive right it's to make
these people that are on the show seem
cool and aspirational and interesting to
watch and engaging by virtue of that you
it has to look polished which I think
can lead to people thinking that's
contrived in an bollocks which isn't
true it's not scripted however there are
what's called villa producers and these
are the point of contact between the
cast's the primary point of contact
between the cast and the production team
and what they'll do is they'll come into
the villa into the garden which is
usually where everybody is and just take
people off to one side to the evidence
so meaning you've had an argument
because both of us like Yusef and it's
the trials as much it is its I can't
believe the first time that we videoed a
podcast you decided to we're sure sorry
go on we the first podcast we ever
recorded he wore bright green trousers
you still got those I still have I was
until the day you promise me you won't
listen I promise of burn the green
high-tops so I mean I'm just I just
[ __ ] despaired only um anyway what
was I saying what was that scene that's
you one chance to pick that glass I know
goes back on the carpet was back on the
carpet
yes Oh Villa producers they come in and
mean you have had an argument about the
fact that we like you sir and what
you'll do is you'll come over and she'll
say so Julie how do you how do you feel
about - about you Charlie you just had
with Chris oh well you know like I'm a
little bit worried because I thought
meenu's if we're gonna get it on but
it's turned out that he actually likes
Chris instead now and I'm feeling a bit
with what I think you should do
maybe grab Youssef go off the far side
have a little chat with him and then you
go over are you touching your boobs whoa
you are you are you're used to audio
only
and we've got video today you don't sell
flopping around I mean well yeah you
just immunity so and then say go the far
side and have a chat but when you go
over the far side you will see like this
setup
shitloads or an army of cameraman
outside of the boundary of the house all
pointing in your direction right so they
don't the show is not scripted but is
there a structure yet absolutely if the
thing that everybody needs to remember
when they're watching the violent is
that there's only 24 hours in a day and
if you produce any content as a cast
member as a Islander as it's called up
until 4:00 a.m. ish the next night at 8
p.m. that would be
edited and be on TV how many editors do
they have they must have a team so we
there's a whole bunch of things that are
surprising about it probably one of the
most surprising things was there the
villa that we were in I think it's a
different Villa now I haven't watched
season three so I'm not sure the villa
that we were in was very very nice and
had the largest natural water pool in
all of Europe was huge its massive so I
was it was absolutely huge any was
saltwater as well so it was just crazy
this millionaire French guy French
investors house at Villa and he had the
exact same villa brick for brick in
France so used whenever the exact same
on the things the same get the same
layout the same masonry work if you just
a command a and select all come on see
my man V yeah
return its worthless when you're trying
to fill it down it needs to all be green
don't spout the formatting then don't
know when you're copying it over and
it'll be--it'll I have the layout if any
of its red and you can tell you know you
won't
yeah you have to have enough to wrote
like book but boy if you ever enough for
what you wouldn't run out of funds
couldn't make it rich
so we go out of the villa
sometimes I'll get to that in a second
when we went out of the villa it looked
like Basra yeah there is rolls and this
is without exaggeration a hundred
industrial unit corrugated iron like
what you'd see on shipping containers on
the back of these huge freighters
they're coming over and in there's four
in a row production off it's always huge
air-conditioning units on the back two
in a row Caroline flax changing room
five in a circle task team though guys
that do the challenges like it's wood
workshop and all the rest of it all of
these have just been shipped over and
you go out and you have no you're just
this tiny little gnat like doing just
going I fancied a bird and you go out
and you're just like talking to hell
this is hunting actually it's a very new
you are you going to do that sci-fi
horror kind of
Cenarion just realized how much how much
of a bastard that operation is it is and
this was the first one and it's got
exponentially bigger so season one was
probably a quarter as popular as season
two which is probably a quarter as
popular as season three so I can only
imagine that that level of extremity is
being taken third so yeah you go out I
didn't so the number of producers and
and you feel like you're living in a
simulation yeah like when you go out The
Truman Show isn't it where everything's
engineer like conversations or engineer
the environments engineering everyone's
watching everything that you're doing
yeah I mean the first time I went
outside and couldn't believe just how
many of these things that there's a full
on-site canteen they've got both drivers
working on rotation 24 hours a day
shipping people from the accommodation
where they've bought a whole hotel for
like two and a half months while watches
for the team just for the team just for
the production team they've got like a
team of 60 security who are on rotation
at all times around the villa around the
villa but also just around the
production place right and they're
checking in at the top like bebe we've
got a gray Ford Mondeo just driving down
the hill John can you look I know no
worries mate don't worry it's just the
Domino's guy again for John so yeah is
it scripted no it's not and but do they
poke the storylines yeah they definitely
do but there has to be a narrative like
and I think editing you can create any
narrative you want from quite small
amount of data which I guess is why you
know with politicians they so you know
the Ed Miliband video that was going
round where it looked like he was just
psychotic cuz he just kept repeating
weird phrases and it's become a bit it's
because they just someone uploaded the
entire take of five minutes but he knows
that he's gonna get chopped into 20
seconds or something so he has to keep
repeating so then when I said it in 45
different ways yeah actually got it
right well the water on the rhetoric
put it aside get on to the negotiating
table and come together and then just
keep iteration of that
Yeah right why mean one of the things
that you can't do which actually sucks a
little bit is there's no second takes
and if it's scripted there would be I
mean you can't do stuff like you don't
get a second chance to say the same
thing to people in terms of an
impression and that means that the
reaction can't be contrived like the
guys that are going on here the guys
that do Geordie Shore the 16 seasons
deep that probably could have had
sufficient media training to actually be
able to fake a response mm-hmm you've
picked [ __ ] Stephanie 18 hairdresser
from wicked and dropped her in the
middle of me often and said right
Stephanie we're just gonna have to take
that again can you just do the same
reaction please
okay heads gonna explode yeah yeah so
that's so it's all first-time there's no
nothing ever gets done again so the
challenges that they do move as
challenges to win dates and stuff like
that those do get second takes that much
more highly produced and the dates are
as well right one of the reasons for
that is that in the villa you've got
controlled camera setups we've come in
today and we've done this is the first
time that we're videoing something in
here - the first time that the guys that
they're recording it had to come in and
set up and the longest amount of time of
anything was set up but if you were to
come in and do it again it would be
won't drop it straight in so little
known fact about live Island on the week
before we went in on season one they did
an entire six day dry run with a whole
separate cast exactly the same purely so
that they could get the camera angles
and the lighting right well just they
don't have to do all that while you're
less so there's a pair of Italian twins
that come in on mine like season two or
season three or something like that
I did three up so two out of three okay
and they had a different pair of twins
so everything is the same the same
storylines Jess Hays
who's the girl that one mm-hmm was in
the dry run and was producing such good
content during that that they said right
pull her out
we're gonna put her in the main one next
week and there's a girl called Naomi who
was the one that actually got quite a
bit of backlash she's like felt fit
blonde one and she was supposed to go in
at the start and they were like she
ended up being what just waiting in the
orchid for like two and a half weeks
ready for her to go in because she'd
been like slipstream by this girl who'd
been proven to be interesting but one of
the other things and God try and sort of
go from start to finish so that I don't
miss anything before you go out there
you guys might remember this cuz we were
sort of in pretty good contact when I
went out I went out and spent everybody
does all of the starting cast spend a
week of media lockdown in Majorca and
the south coast of New York with a
chaperone who doesn't let you out of
their sight
24 hours a day for a full week before
you go so I got picked up on the Sunday
morning going in on the Friday or
Saturday morning going in on the Friday
following and from that moment did not
have thought laptop access to the
Internet access to friends knowledge of
anything that was going on and you then
basically kept under lock and key you're
allowed to go out and you can go to the
gym and stuff like that but each cast
member has like a geo-fenced area know
that they're allowed to move with it so
you can't interact with other there's no
chance that they would be out having a
coffee and you'd bump into that person
and the reason that they have you on
media lockdown is twofold firstly so
that you are beginning to get
conditioned you get bit at the time you
start to chill out you start to think
about the what's sort of coming up so
they've got control of you and so that
you can go and do media obligations when
you need to go an interview with the
reveal magazine later on and then we're
going to do some press shots and then
we're going to do whatever the other
thing is so that they can start to
reveal stuff about the cast members to
online and to the public back in the UK
the only fear of loosing it
all right so if I was to go into a
corner shop I wouldn't be allowed to go
in without a chaperone
one he makes sure he knows I'm going
home if I was twenty fifteen we had
swaps in the gym so I was in it 8:00
a.m. which was fine for makes a train in
the morning but we have slot to like
8:00 a.m. until 9:00 and then a half an
hour window where the next person would
go through and I didn't fully unlock
down then that's incredible
currently it's no no no TV I took it
like a hard drive out with me and was in
that was the first time I've said this
before it's the first time that I
finished a book for it had no
distractions
and what did you do so sunbathed a lot
trained a lot I was in a deficit so I
hated my life a lot which was just so
just thought about food no it was good
it was honestly that week was probably
one of the most liberating I've had you
think about it you don't have to think
about you know Haney anywhere else other
than exactly wave of me as my presence
is possible with no sense of guilt doing
so let go of the fact that like this is
a weird situation I've got a chaperone
and the novelty of that's gone it's like
I can just living life and personally I
found it incredibly liberating I think a
lot of the guys I know that were cast
when I was there struggled a bit more if
you are naturally social heavily social
you're really gonna struggle because
it's just you and this person
and for the most part they've got tasks
that they need to be doing they still at
work it's just that they're at work
whilst babysitting you and making sure
that you don't run and grab exercise an
introverts dream but works perfect for
me right yeah
well not really because you crossed
someone watching watching you the whole
time thankfully thankfully my
it's like being in a taxi like you can
talk to them if you want to but like I
would give it to the driver a five-star
rating if they just didn't talk to me
would you want a hello and a goodbye
maybe but I'm not so much I hate hate
forced low-level interaction people
yeah which is why either of us on Long
Island I think would I like honestly I
think I would become clinically
depressed ya know with the pre pre bit
just the proof it was great
yeah and we go back Wow how much
operating good before the live I was
fantastic there yeah I only put me in
this Ravello loads of people I had to
say things and speak and it was justice
so I would attend recent lovely tricey
you instructed me and then have an army
of cameramen outside the door and I'd
pay to see you in a bond I would love to
see you can you not speak to the right
people to get actually no don't you have
to keep any like rope or paracetamol
away from me why do you think that you
wouldn't i've already not beyond the
limits of paracetamol today why do we
really why do you think you wouldn't do
very well if you were on a reality TV
show it's so that my i think it would be
a personality clash to be the most
diplomatic way of saying it like the
having seen the first episode none of
the people I finished the first oh no
see I couldn't even finish the episode
so obviously men six weeks with those
people more than five minutes yeah the
first episode yeah so we can do it I
will get onto that a second so other
stuff that's kind of cool I guess
there's if you're in Big Brother you've
seen this I guess or it's quite heavily
alluded to that they never know that
there's other people around and that the
cameraman like don't interact with them
and they go in and change it in the
house overnight mm-hmm
they do make amends like if there's a
day however going on the next morning
they'll lay the table overnight that
sort of stuff will happen but you're
very
very aware without being conscious I'm
sorry no you're very conscious without
being aware of the production process
going on so you know that there's 70
cameras so forth chatting right now the
B or camera under the table they're
looking at me to be a little one of
their underneath the lamp that be you
can you can see them all yeah little
little sort of bulbs CCTV ones but
they're very very well placed so they're
just innocuous just slide around the
same way that you would have like a home
security system right what do you mean
conscious but not aware so the second
part of that is that there's guys with
[ __ ] bazookas like they're real like
looking at Jodie Marsh from three miles
away once I on the beach one of them
like a sea Sun photographer ones there's
those and they're in key positions
they've got like the biggest field of
vision around the garden and those ones
there's a guy there's a man under a hood
like looking through that and moving
around and as you're walking past you
can you say in my permit yeah
you can aren't me but like told to
attain the top they're told not to talk
to you and if you do they come over the
time I in the tub you are so there's a
tunnel system why they tell you off for
doing [ __ ] so they don't need to send
someone in every time venerian well I
mean why is it one of the things that I
don't think anyone who watches the show
would believe is that it's really really
[ __ ] boring and that's not me being
facetious or in any way it's anyone
that's on it would agree mmm I get to
see 45 minutes 40 minutes out of a day
from muster that's the best paper yet
from multiple people's lives so times up
by 14 yeah we talking like about 350
hours of life so you probably got like a
good bit every 24 hours
well it's there's more about your
highlight it's more like your experience
it's not about the not about the end
result that goes on TV it's more about
what you experience hmm well yeah yeah
yeah okay you were like Tiberias oh good
baby fat
was a cracking moment not a cracking
32nd rise now let's get back to the
remaining like 23 hours you know it's
there's no 82nd no entertainment but no
because you've got no phone you gotta
bring a book it couldn't bring book in
not for smart but they were allowed to
do gold who was the born-again Christian
on my series was allowed to bring a
Bible II and I thought what I've got The
Selfish Gene Richard Dawkins any chance
I could bring this militant atheism no
no not that and so yeah there's all the
cameras around and you are very
conscious by say of what's going on but
very quickly also adapt to the situation
a lot of this stuff's done behind
one-way mirrors so there's a mirror
above the kitchen there's a mirror in
the girls changing rooms his mirrors
around and behind that there's a lot of
stuff that's going on as well with
cameras and so obviously that's I mean
completely oblivious know wherever and
the little ones can just swivel around
and you kind of don't know you're always
miked up there'll be a sound guy that'll
come in twice a day morning and night
change your batteries out so you put a
microphone on you don't have to have it
next to you bed but the second you go
even if you'll show the bastard right on
put it on and look I'm over the time I
Chris you've got your microphone on is
it like a house like an elastic band
elastic bands thing that's then got
biggie clip the thing onto and then that
comes down there yeah let me show one
back I'm back back but back to you
though I like I'm pretty much at all
times which isn't waterproof so again
just was that it's worth like each one's
worth at 250 quid so you gotta be
waterproof bond back up in the market we
have 14 14 sales per year so yeah the
the fact that you've got to get 45
minutes of content out of a full day
inevitably means that they need to push
and hurry the storylines along a lot so
poke you with a stick a little bit yes
to they need to make a like that they
need to expedite what's happening but
they can't have 14 day wooing period
where someone finally cooks up the
courage to ask me to hold someone else's
time
needs to happen no sorry how do they
encourage that we said when they take
you aside for example is that eliciting
your opinion or is it like oh do you
want to go the fluffer comes in here oh
no no it's not it's more about its I
think everyone's conscious another thing
to consider is everybody's conscious
that they're there a lot of the people
there to get time on TV you haven't gone
on TV to not be on TV so what they term
producing content is doing something
which will make the edit or doing
something which will contribute to the
Edit the final production of that
particular episode will having that just
just imagining how often Youssef would
be on the others alright I feel like it
would be constantly so I'd imagine like
let's say people having a chart and then
someone goes like they'll have to be
like okay chop that use of surprised
save as a file and then like slip it
into other conversation so you is what
they're doing like x-factor for example
where they splice audience reaction is
with things that didn't reacting to you
redo that minute well just chop in so I
just want that whenever we say something
they need a bank if like seven emotions
and we can just throw them in whenever
Chris furious yeah Johnny nine story so
that's a good that's a really good point
about them noting stuff down actually
alluded to them transcribing things you
will have someone listening to your
channel on the mic almost 24 hours a day
and I came out in really really weird so
while I was in there the majority of the
conversations that you have have to be
about what's going on and if you begin
to talk about stuff from the outside
world common friends that you've got
that aren't in the villa they'll come
over the town and they'll tell you
Ireland owes can you please stop talking
about the outside world thank you really
see you actually have more freedom in
most prisons then yeah like you thought
that's thought police I thought in every
so or well II
like any you can it's you right it's
when you say it like that it sounds
really terrible book yeah so you can't
there's no entertainment you have to
just be with yourself with other people
and you can't talk about anything apart
from the inane activities very what
everyone else is doing without anything
saving it without them yeah this is what
I mean when I say they're exploring like
it it's some stupid to say that you're
in this ten million pound villa with
half-naked girls wait really boring mmm
like you there's only so many times that
you can talk about Omar in that chat
that he had last night and how he proper
mugged or off the rug like how many
times can you say that because nothing
else has happened because there's a
reflection period mmm
understand there's these peaks of
activity that are then followed by an
anger chamber of it happening and once
that's been completed you need to wait
for the next thing to happen but during
that time you can only talk about stuff
that's going on in development people
drink alcohol so you I thought when I
went on I was expecting it to be like
acts on the beach or Geordie Shore I had
a lot of experience of being around the
guys from geordie shore running club
night in Newcastle and I thought
brilliant days in the Sun nights getting
pissed this could be sweet got there and
you are limited to two drinks really
won't be a warm wine or any combination
thereof it's weird cuz it's like they're
trying to create this incubation chamber
but they're not putting any accelerants
in there either it's like I think what
to be honest the alcohol thing although
I've wanted to stop someone at the time
for the restrictions looking back I can
see why they do it because if you look
at the groove that love islands carved
out for itself in programming
it isn't Geordie Shore into not X on the
beach it's not as a state classy it's
not as fluffy as something like Made in
Chelsea or TOWIE but it's not actually
all that far off when you look at it
high in reduction value everyone in
there yeah there's arguments and stuff
like that but it's not because someone's
out of control it's because of all the
rules in the tunnel were like no no
alcohol no red foods no cheese
no miss matching socks like you know
frown food touching beige for you know
you might [ __ ] oh I'd be yeah ruin
terrible ruined so yeah the one of the
one of the problems that you come across
is that you just bought like you've got
nothing to talk about and then like you
say you've restricted on how many times
you can talk about the same situation
but one of the things that does happen
like when they've when they've got their
content for the day
there's less food a little bit less
pressure and because the live show on
the year that we did it was on a
Thursday night I think is either a
Thursday or Friday night know it was a
Thursday night what it meant was that
there's no show on a Friday in a
recapture on a Saturday so you had
Thursday's off completely and that was
complete that was liberation you could
do whatever you wanted and the this
little filming on Thursdays they're
still filming but what they say is look
guys just don't do anything don't do
anything exciting the cameras are
rolling but we don't want to put it in
so just as long as you guys so happy to
talk about back home and stuff like that
but you know six days a week if not
being able to do those is actually quite
quite trying how I wonder how much
footage they'd actually take from that
off date so the imagination is already
much really well because one of the
problems is there's no show on a Friday
and then there's a recap show on a
Saturday I think the schedule is
slightly different but it's still got
time off when you don't have a day of
broadcasting and each episode is one day
how would you fit stuff from an extra
day into that one day doing a stunt you
can't you can't Pat that him and they
could just use it later or something up
there so words I contrived another
another one of the things so this is one
of my fears right before I went on
remember that Jade Goody incident way
which she'll be showing you issues like
she should go home and they were burning
effigies of pigs that look like Jake
good in the streets is on Big Brother
show Bocchetti Bay is like big Bollywood
star and
my I had in the back of my head mmm just
don't don't do something that's that
newsworthy and obviously you like I've
never said anything like that in my life
but [ __ ] knows more than Danvers and
then with the editing as well and
because you never get to see what the
final edit looks like and when we were
the first season I'm going on now you
understand you know how it's going to be
cut what the sort of flow is going to be
what kind of end result they're looking
for us quite fluffy right quite nice
they're not trying to make anyone look
like a tit mm-hmm
whereas before you go and you don't know
if it's some character assassination
waiting in the wings and I was pretty
pretty terrified and as he says like
selective editing such it so what I'm
interested in that as you said I was
looking forward to there being a bit
more alcohol and a bit more freedom to
so clearly from that perspective you
weren't afraid to to not loose a little
bit with your inhibitions and say
whatever whereas on the other side like
not that you are at risk of like saying
something racist or whatever but do you
do you think it's because you're
self-employed that you didn't have a
sense of oh I better not say something
that might have a repercussions or
recourse later on yeah that was not that
was definitely a big deal um of the guys
on my season I think if you discount me
as company director from being
self-employed ie
not on temporary worksite work mm-hm I
think it was only two of the people who
didn't either work for their family or
were self-employed as model laborer
something similar I wasn't worse and who
were employed yes
outside of that before you died it does
matter then as much if you haven't
joined doesn't matter to them if their
yeah but the point the point is you can
go back on-site tomorrow you can pretty
much say anything believe that you got
your dick oh like do you know I mean
it's desert ly fine yeah whereas if you
return to KPMG you all like oh I send
their way around other than saying write
about it to be self-employed well from
from this perspective yeah that's just
more protective for the brand and yeah
that was your right but think
that were on there I honestly think that
a lot of them would have been would have
acted exactly the same anyway
and so it's a teeming character that
shows through regardless of
what position they're going to go back
to at the end but yeah I was I was
always conscious of that and I think
that you can't get around the fact that
you know for all that they try and make
it really really naturalistic like
you're on [ __ ] TV you're on TV
you're not unlike Fox Network you're on
something which at least yeah so it
mimics it mimics a natural environment
right but that's the goal but everyone
else is going through the same
experience at the same time which is
takes the pressure off it's a little bit
one of the things one of the things that
you want to do is bond over the the
alien nature of the experience and you
can't break the fourth wall like that
either because you're not allowed to
talk about it so one of the first things
we want to do I remember on the first
and the second day all that all of us
wanted to do was talk about the last
week we've done in lockdown because we
love where were you living I was living
here I was on the poor or I went to the
gym at this time or did you go and get
frozen yogurt from this place yeah yeah
cuz that's you I've never met this
person before but you've got some weird
common experience that both of you have
gone through incredibly recently and
you're like this is and you're not Brian
over this is this is exactly what I want
to talk about personally for me that was
exactly what I wanted to talk about it's
like I wanted to discuss my experience
how I felt how I you know that I wanted
to understand that way nothing wasn't
thinking inside you like right here I am
with this person this is weird
boundaries around what we can and can't
talk about you like do you like lemons
what's the safe top like yeah it was it
was a little bit difficult do you think
of the song today the Sun is bright and
the other I like I think so too
yeah it was it made it difficult to it
made it difficult for me to be authentic
with that
I wasn't tremendously interested in what
was going on in the villa and I think
that made me a bad Islander to to a
degree it made me about about castmate
but I think a lot of people are like
that and then it's just varying degrees
of playing the game or forgetting it um
you mentioned the Sun another really
interesting thing is the we do not have
any idea of the time mm-hmm so when you
live in the villa they do not give you
the time since you did you wake up so
yeah even retrospectively but there's
nothing there's at no point do you know
what time unit no never
so you have the phones that they give
you the mobile phones that they have on
the show or got the wrong and different
times on the clocks on the wall all have
the wrong time on you get into the car
the drivers car to go on a date or to go
out on your day off
drivers changed his watch clock on there
has changed why don't think why I'm not
too sure I'd be quite interested to know
that reason I think is that by breaking
up the routine it allowed them to
determine the schedule of the day and it
meant that they can choose right this
when you get up this is when so intense
like I feel like I had so I spent ten
days in the monastery in December and it
was way more freedom that I knew this
like and you weren't allowed to speak I
wasn't in the air and I was all look at
people at least for very Denise you
weren't allowed to speak the things you
wanted to yeah which is worse actually
so yeah you can have really asinine
pointless conversations but you can't be
can still talk that's all you can say
mmm weird
and then I'm but I'm hearing this and
I'm like buddy how like be in some like
Norwegian it's a high-security prison is
to get a TV how much of so like I
watched a bit more than seven minutes
yeah and I think the thing that I find
most interesting is the version of you
that you see on there to me seems like a
like it may be a small part of you that
you've had to like right I need to bring
out everything I've got of this side of
my personality here for three weeks you
know it you know it's like it's like you
as quite a nice mannered intellectual
guy who's Charlie carne and all the rest
of it but under the right circumstances
you can fill himself with adrenaline and
pick 310 kilos off the ground that was a
very very minor part that's actually
probably not that similar to the rest of
you but you do actually seem to have a
bit of a speciality in it and you've
been able to I see so the psychologists
saying that you don't have a single
personality because you are never a
consistent being throughout the day
you're probably 14 or 15 sub
personalities that you draw on depending
on the context mm-hmm so you have like a
going into the corner shop personality
or like a because you can wait a bit or
like speaking with your friends or being
at work and all these things are just
different masks that you go on and take
off depending on their yeah circumstance
so maybe you had that available because
of the environment you working in our
I've got to put that one on cuz I'm with
these kind of people today so or 3x I
think I think that's a really good
analogy and you know and I wanted to try
and make it up we are making this
podcast about the process and about the
show itself
if someone doesn't understand to know me
you know my background it might not make
as much sense but I do think that
there's definitely people that I've seen
in other seasons Sophie great news in
season two I know is cut from a similar
cloth as myself a little bit mindful a
little bit introverted teams of
intellectual interests and academic and
stuff like that and I know that she
struggled similarly as well ran it she
is also she's been out doing it played
the game with modeling and didn't like
it sort of a little bit ofnot grammar
book you know sort of like bikini shoots
and stuff like that and being in that
world nightlife world hooked him up with
for ten years so my trade is putting
these these people I'm putting people
similar to those who I was in the villa
with into nightclubs yeah but I only
have to deal with that atmosphere for 20
seconds of time because they want to go
inside and get drunk and I get to and
like do a matte single single rep max
one rep max and then max effort and then
go Ally alone and then yeah it's a bit
like if you do a job interview you
anyone can convince somebody for 20
minutes that they're not a psychopath
hmm and then the problem is the what do
you do for the next 200 years
yeah but this was this is one of the
problems that I don't wanna run in there
and I sold my story to the producers as
one that looking back now was me playing
their game
remembering that I should get myself on
take me out of love I live in the space
of two and a half years mmm
I know I understood what they wanted to
hear so if anyone wants us wants me to
do a little segment on one of the next
life hacks on how to get yourself in
reality TV yeah I think they'll be
demand for us so did you know what you
know what we did James James who's one
of our city managers the only reason
that he wasn't on X on the beach was
because of the operation like a
logistical issue but he was not even in
the UK and on I think about 15 minutes
of briefing from me and like right gonna
say this and you're gonna say this get
some stories that's similar to this and
did to do and that was it they only
needed to see one Skype twice and he was
so interested then he was booked well if
there is a method there's death there's
definitely a method but you know the
listeners can think about what what do
you think producers want to hear you
know what what is it that they're
looking for out of people but so so they
don't want people discussing space-time
and mindfulness which is what I know you
really want to talk about but that's why
I actually did talk about is it where
you're in there so I got on one of the
off days i sat down with Jordan Hulk saw
the big dude that's it do you
previously know him no I knew some of
the people that were going in
not gonna say how because it'll get
someone in trouble but I worked out how
some of the other people in fact Nara
[ __ ] I am BSA so yes you were gonna say
all along that was the cleverest thing
to do but wasn't right but I've just
decided I've just decided so [ __ ] it
and Marlon he was on season 2 did you
watch season 2 of love island no of
course you didn't
so I've worked of what I was bits of
season 2 yeah so I watched very little
of season 1 okay so there was a there
was a mixed-race girl I want to say I'm
not too sure why she's from that may be
butchering this but it's sort around
Indian heritage go Kamali and she said
make pies from London long show of it
the very very first intro which I know
both of you have seen where I'm on the
plane there's a girl there's a girl
there's a girl that walks past and I get
it hey um that was Marlon that was
Marlon and I was on taking out with her
two years before then she messaged me as
soon as I got off and said oh yeah I'm
gonna go and film another one of these
there on Joe but you tell me who it is
I was like [ __ ] rights to it thank
you very much she went and then filmed
so anyone who's watching season one and
Netflix rewind there's a girl that walks
in to the first scene where Luis is in
bed and he's in bed with a girl but
there's a girls like boom and she's in
like sort of like sexy pajamas and she
walks away really really turned that's
her as well and then she went to go and
do a third one and it was with the
Italian twins that getting this like
fancy Lamborghini so twelve hours later
I was able to work out to other people
got two of the sets of people that were
on the show I see although she was you
know she gave me some cheat code so his
lack of life beyond the are a trifle
triangles gets a waiver limited lives
omnipotence and car drives and water
yeah yeah well that's not your heart
what about this one
great um so where are we I'm trying to
think about what else there was that
Mister oh yes so we were talking about
him
well the space-time thing so I'd
recently watched interstellar I'd read
the book Kip Thorne who was the
consultant a strong on surrogates
consultant physicist on the show and he
did a partnership a partner book to it
the science behind interstellar I got
half an hour with Jordan it was one of
the older glads on the show and we were
late in the bedroom just chatting away
and I was telling him about why I'd
learned in the book about time dilation
from being close to a black hole mm-hmm
when I came out and then went back the
next day to film my it's Chris
see you later on thanks for the this
this and this I was sat in the canteen
of Basra of all of their corrugated iron
things and there was a man who put his
rifle down next to me and told you war
stories yeah and two guys came Salva and
they said I made it Chris um sort of I'm
sort of all right we're right where to
the sound engineers we've been we were
one of the people it was listening to
your mic um so we we listened to like
pretty much everything you've said for
the last three and a half weeks why
surreal um you know that that thing
about gravity growing time dilation
could you tell us a little bit more I
was like [ __ ] hell that's the most
innocuous little discussion that I had
but there is someone listening to the
Islanders at all times there is nothing
that goes under the radar and there's a
lot of stuff that was said in there that
an awful lot of talk like about partying
and drugs and you know stuff that would
be libelous but if it was if they
decided to put together an absolute
character asylum they go to jail anyone
mmm in a heartbeat because especially
when you have people that are very
outgoing and charismatic and kind of
extroverted they the tiny little
slip-ups I was concerned about they're
like [ __ ] Tanner penny they're just
like yeah Scotty gunning them although
they couldn't ruin you if they wanted to
they could do but I guess those guys
were so ballsy then they were able to
push though were able to discount or any
fear of that
coming on which led to them actually
being of the content was so much more
energetic and so much more engaging do
you think it was consciously discounting
it or they would just just didn't care
[ __ ] it yeah I think I genuine just
think that most of the guys that would
doing that just didn't give a [ __ ] I
don't think is like a consideration I
think it's just that's again that's why
the good cast members yeah definitely
good customers because they don't have
that filter whereas for me I was very
mindful of the oddness of the experience
a lot of the time so we we have this
experience quite quite a bit I imagine
you will be now increasingly with the
podcasts where you'll have said
something in an article that you wrote
in 2011 and forgotten about it and then
you'll get a message from someone about
like a line in it there's something that
you didn't you like oh my god I've got
to be careful about what I put in the
public domain because it might be
recommended in there forever
yeah and it is it's never something
cringy but it's like something a
recommendation that you made that you
maybe no longer agree with yeah there's
sometimes like oh hey three minutes 42
on new video and you're like oh yeah yes
I mean I've never I've never had that
before
and the podcast has been incredibly
liberating for me to actually finally
speak the truth forward about stuff that
I'm interested in after so long it's
kind of doing this and you know I it
must sound or it might sound like I'm I
didn't enjoy the the process of growing
a lot on I really did I didn't enjoy it
for the reasons of like being loud being
in there the little bit of adoration and
social equity that you get coming out I
enjoyed the experience for the
experience I was transfixed by the
production process I wanted to know how
all of the rushes worked and why there
were all of these different cameras and
stuff like that and that to me was
really really interesting but maybe it
didn't make me the best Islander because
I was I was far too detached from the
actual narrative and of what was going
on inside of it mm-hm so yeah it was
despite you've experienced something
there may be 50 people I've ever
probably will ever thought for the
length of time that I was hard to do
it's not about many experiences like
that that you
that anyone will ever experience no bu
right like if you're living there in a
kind of square peg thing where you're
you're enjoying a slightly different
aspect of the whole thing it's like
coming in here recording the podcast but
just being like transfixed colors in the
rear that's like well great but it's you
mean you might still hit a couple of
yeah you do you end up you end up
striking out a little bit more
unfortunately I think you know if you
are listening or watching though you're
on that one
oh well oh yeah football you you're on
the one that's facing you you're on the
cancer isn't that one look like it's
facing me this is look like where our
case is to facing you maybe they're all
facing you all just looking at the
troubles have you thought that because
you're Egyptian this is just
surveillance this is all just complying
with the way you're finally getting in
there don't you this has just been
facial ID so we've got three coming
through you know exactly the realms or
they have the spinning your head can
replicate you know terrible so a couple
of other stuff that was things that were
really interesting you get days out of
the villa so the Thursday or the day off
the day before the day there's no airing
we actually got taken out of the villa
and we were the one of the villa
producers took us out there me remember
security book they were like right we're
gonna go to the most non-british beach
that we can find would be like it do
Spanish and German Beach so no one
recognizes yeah exactly exactly because
the show was being aired at the time
right I don't even know if they'll be
allowed to do this now because it shows
so much bigger and I don't even know if
you'd be able to get away from that but
just so weird just being just sat on a
beach bunch of German people German is
Spanish so what what happened the
producer taking us out there and it said
right lads
I'm telling you know if you do anything
to cause a scene you're all [ __ ]
right okay no worries for me I was like
I'm out the villa I can talk about why
one they took me to a corner shop and
they bought me sweets
[Laughter]
others believe me be hit this is it like
you know you you tie it up into a
mistake for so long in the new I'm gonna
extend the rope by centimeter today and
yes yeah so but so that was again that
was me and that was my level of probably
neuroticism to a degree about the
experience right
we've bought your football they've just
have a kick around amongst yourselves in
the time that she said have a kick
around amongst yourselves John who's now
on TOWIE John Clarke had found five
German guys they'd said all right that's
fancier don't you kick around yeah yeah
Oh boys boys because we've got game over
er John John and his producer come over
John look like I do not want any hard
tackles or anything I can't believe I'm
letting you do this and I have to
explain that on the show
so it was there's not vote for when
Germany were hosting Lee what's the
advert for I'm not sure like a bunch of
a bunch of Germans get in the lift and
the guy had been singing in German he
shuts up and they're like and his sons
there and then he starts singing so what
actually happened was she went to the
bathroom and came back to find us stood
on the beach with her hands on our
chests singing god save the queen
so I mean and it just went from that we
won 3-2 know if fYI no injuries no
injuries you know but did what surface
beach beach beach
he was saying I can't explain that
broken leg is it like if someone if the
next day on unlove Island someone
supplements got broken Zygon we didn't
have any [ __ ] footage of it I see
that might imagine how'd that happen
very bad day but he's enough that would
have been recorded to turned over in
birds record 24 hours and just can't
explain it so some of the places that
there aren't cameras are partially tell
you next three weeks they're walking
around just loaded up on travedoc
[ __ ] lucid then wouldn't true just I
think to print out a version of their
face and stick it on there smiling so
that they can mock you me yeah you oh no
I got a 3d one 3d what's that called
deep something deep fake it's ours
yeah thing that they so with it we I
think was like you need 18 minutes of
footage of someone's face just talking
and no how are you there you can
transpose it over really got wonderful
bomber and just so God and so yeah
another one of the another one of the
times where now weather isn't cameras is
in the toilet which is really nice not
in the toilet so there's no there's no
cameras in the totally said in other
changing rooms in the there's no
changing rooms there's no berries
listen back to the podcast you said
there is a one-way mirror in the female
changing room oh sorry I was referring
to like you do wardrobe that they are
say okay like a changing room as opposed
to like a a place weighed like a locker
room oh okay call it when they're like
flossing the towel and yeah exactly
that's what total but the the shower the
shower and the bath are both opened
there's no doors and there's cameras
pointing directly at the showers really
since each but Sharan trunks or even
what the girls like the girls chose to
the lads didn't really mind so much for
the girls shouting bikini
and like if you walked in at the wrong
time that you could be mmm bright is
what you might spoil some of the
internet some of the upcoming yeah not
only I guess people can still they can
still hear you in the toilets they can
hear like them but no this door over
here are you still wearing the mic
yeah that's good point in room actually
yeah
so you would have full if I just well
there's two guys or something this thing
just pooed yeah Wow
I mean I've come from both ends of the
spectrum I'm like from gravity
time-dilation to [ __ ] grunts fake booze
yeah [ __ ] grunts was there ever were you
ever worried about I'd be talking to
them but I see you're not good for play
sorry you're in a villa it's war it's
hot relaxed lots of women not wearing
very much you were just wearing trunks
yeah
ever a risk big erection ever worry
about that
no not really no is it is it just never
cross your mind
it didn't I did sneak vigor in them so
just in case just in case I mean you do
not I mean John John Clarke went soft on
camera and they made a joke about it and
I was like well maybe if you mention to
me cuz I saw would you up so basically
before you go in the security guy will
go and check through all your bag and
this is at the end of the lockdown week
so getting ready get going and they'll
go through your luggage and they'll take
out everything that you've got too much
branding on this t-shirt
sorry mate not gonna be able to do that
this pair of scissors will give you a
replacement pair that's in there like
sharp has a scissors and stuff like that
roaming that everyone's are undergone a
very strict psychometric I was gonna
advise now let's say someone yeah very
very strict one any history of
depression any history of anxiety today
how does this make you feel how will it
make you feel if you can't speak to your
friends and family how Siskin and then
the most rigorous sexual health check
do you ever heard of in your life by
it's a fingers up but then goes anywhere
no fingers Noel I'm brother no balls no
fingers on balls
figs umbrella whyis
obsessed I'm just wondering is a measure
of rigor and you give them imagine so
like I think in terms of in terms of
sexual health history and stir oh I see
they're not doing loads of like weird
did you have any of the furrow hanging
hanging upside down by my progress know
that do they just look over your history
and go what have you in haven't you had
fine cut
fine fine fine did happens right now
yeah exactly right and what is it Harley
Street in them mmm well it's like a lot
of the big dick big try hitbox yeah so I
was like you going that it's outside
it's like Ferrari Ferrari Maserati
Lamborghini well and went up to the top
floor of this sort of town house it's
innocuous-looking little town house and
there's just this woman in a tight dress
with massive VPL and you don't know what
be realistic I just was like visible pun
line there you go here but hey yeah it's
weird that you have to deduce it right
is it any mind palace left it's the
social interaction or the boot the boot
strap program in case it's in behind
spending money I got the free trial I'm
not paying for that I'll be finding the
cheap version doesn't delay I'll deal
with it it'll be fine it and so yeah you
we've had that and we've got him yeah
you're not allowed these scissors you
know a lot this than the other and what
I did was I cut holding the lining of my
toiletries bag and slipped five viagra
in there just in case just you know for
the lot it's very clever as well to have
done that so like Steve
security guys Steve if you're watching
check the lining of people's toilet
party what you cut cut it cut a hole in
it then seal it up again no but like it
is not it's not it's not like going
through [ __ ] customs like he's just
checking to make sure the other one has
anything sharp or stuff that has got too
much browning so it was fairly young it
was like rigorous or the it was thorough
just say look like not it wasn't crazy
but yeah like that was that was I guess
that was my experience when you leave
you are taken to a
like a really nice couple thought up and
deposited a that night you go back to
next day they give you like a checking
out protocol about the price may contact
you these are the things you should and
shouldn't do here is a contact for
management here is a contact for this
than the other
the experience is sort of pretty
well-rounded considering the volume that
they need to look after and his people
coming and going honest every week and
the level of cavity given yes obviously
planning think week system is no it's so
if and remembering that this is when
we've done it it was the first time mate
everything this is the first endeavor of
that kind and yeah it was I was
impressed with how slick it was and now
obviously they love refined it in three
like over the course of three years and
it would be like a [ __ ] machine yeah
so what would you do differently if you
were going country was going to ask
don't miss the next one is it in a month
you so it'll be in a month yeah so one
of the reasons I think that it's been
poor Netflix now only season one to
bring it burn yeah get people really
excited ready for the next season to
come out which would be at the end of
the month unless some of the cast
they're going up there some like some
pretty cool some cool guys a couple of
guys from up north again as well cool so
what would I do differently
ah man the experience of go another fire
them for me was the beginning of a
journey that allowed me to realize who I
really am now that sounds like a so this
really sort of pithy today the statement
about like you know I just went on there
and I was just myself but I wasn't so I
went on there and I played a role but
what it created you realized the divide
or the massively gap and what I also got
exposed to was a high fatal dose of what
that particular network of people are
truly like I want to see party boys and
party girls in the front door of a club
I'm able to box them up in a category
that doesn't have as much of an effect
on me and they could have played the
role with me for twenty seconds as well
right mmm-hmm but they weren't you know
you don't see them 24 hours you don't
know yeah
when you live when you live with them
for three and half weeks like you're
right okay you are really different to
me mmm and it's [ __ ] apparent and
that so if I was to going again what I
would do different here's a B I would be
myself I don't regret the way that I
acted on that because it allowed me to
do stuff like this podcast I love the
all of the pursuits have gotten at the
moment that mindfulness training and
speaking the truth which i think is a
real big deal because I've lied through
my teeth to get myself on there to play
a role of someone that I wasn't
particularly but someone that I knew I
could play the role of would being
yourself get you kicked out earlier or
later do you think later under okay I
could go on I'm pretty certain I could
go on as the person I am now even in
that season and providing I didn't get
stitched with the Edit I think I would I
would have a pretty good chance of
staying on until the end and one of the
reasons is and this is for anyone who's
considering to go on reality TV there's
the the lack of authenticity shows
through really really starkly because
you run out of things that you can think
to say
situations that you can think to create
whereas that's not how we operate our
personalities aren't consciously
manifested on a second-by-second basis
they appear as a byproduct of you
existing and having makeup mm-hmm and
life this it create like well what might
be interesting is saying what wouldn't
it what would live Island Chris say
enough mmm like that's not the way it
was a bit tiring to do that it was it
was it was it was fatiguing but again
for that like a incredibly grateful that
the opportunity one real and as you say
like it's really rare
I could never gonna be very unlikely
that something similar is gonna happen
again and I really enjoyed it but like
the experience for me that when someone
says Oh what was the best thing about
being on the island they're like oh well
when I came out that top three things
probably that happen from love island in
no particular order one of them is that
when it came out on the south coast of
the author it's a really really good
spot for stargazing I'm not really too
sure why and I came out and he was the
night dad laughing it's kind of like
emotional and stuff if anyone's seen the
episode where I leave and I'm like a
little bit upset because I'm leaving the
guys who I've got this bond with and no
matter how invested or not I was in the
experience it was an intense experience
and there was a floating of emotion when
I left and there was a lot of bromance
like in there bill had this connection
with Max and stuff who's the guy went on
to win and say goodbye in was pretty
tough and a few of the bits I like this
sort of bit of a whirlwind because no
one had been prepared when I left know
we didn't know his an eviction that
night so it was kind of just [ __ ] it got
packed my bags [ __ ] right okay see you
later on guys and that I was gone and I
finished my bhakti couples hotel I said
he gave up in this beautiful five-star
kind that Sandals resort thing well
they're all like individual hearts and
they were had finished of finally being
given a big beer as opposed to like a
330 ml one
I had this big beer Southside mitts just
crickets going on it's like finally like
midnight completely clear warm not miked
up anymore not miked up on my own able
to be with my thoughts and you've done
get your phone back yet because they've
still got 24 hours until what's just
happened as nothing it comes the one day
of lieu still to go and have a nice beer
and I looked up and I could just see the
full Milky Way like from Horizon to
Horizon in this silent Trickett couple
of cricket and I could just see this
like sprinkling of light star dust of
the brightest have ever ever seen
thousands of stars
why is that one of the things that I
liked from the island Janome that's not
part that wasn't anything to do with the
experience but for me it was very
meaningful and it might sound it might
sound like a conclusion no it's the it's
the shift in all the accelerates the
acceleration there so listening to that
Peter RTO podcast whoo he did a marathon
swim back and forth to this island and
he said the most emotional thing is
always the the change in gear shift
and so having swam for however many
hours but like in the water and then
finally to be crawling on land is the
most elated incredible experience just
because if they're like oh my god I'm on
land again yeah imagine the same thing
like you looking outside at the sky on
your own hmm no camera well as I've said
you know you asked about um how I
remember the experience and a certain
elements of it I was incredibly mindful
for but I am over time as memories fade
my appreciation of that situation is
degrading and every year it will
continue to degrade which is why if
you've tweeted me a question on Twitter
the answers have been probably pretty
shoddy and no because I a lot of the
situations I can't really remember but
that the Milky Way above I I can't see a
time and I'm not gonna remember it it
wouldn't have held any weather we've
held a lot less meaning if it had just
been that situation by itself it's
almost certainly the it's the result of
and the ending of an experience that
makes you as Yusuf says it's the
contrast because we've just been there
randomly you're having a beer by
yourself [ __ ] do you think my other
stars are nice
yeah instead of it being like a I think
they would have been yeah yeah there
would have been an element of that
because it was so spectacular but yet I
was like serious I want to know what it
was like looking at your phone for the
first time so I didn't have my phone I
left my phone in my business partner oh
right yeah harassing yeah he was looking
after guess this text and I dropped off
my car my iPad a laptop my phone he had
power of attorney on a house purchase
that was going through the towers I I'm
gonna come back he's gonna
absolutely character assassination
they're given the vendor a selling me
this house under the 10 grand just gives
your card cuz I don't I'm just imagining
like you know what mate you seem like a
nice guy give another tasty bro telling
on your phone and they're just being
like I mean okay ramier admin well
that's right like days to go through
yeah do you know you know when it's your
birthday
hmm and you the days just spent doing
admin he was like that but it was like a
full week I can't remember how many
messages I came out to but he was like
hundreds just on Facebook which was like
just friends hmm
so yeah the feather is he fair that mean
from that and then yeah like I say the
young but for me one of the one of the
big takeaways was that I was I was able
to begin a journey that had been
highlighted by a contrast of who I was
pretending to be while I was there and
the role that I was playing and the
understanding that even though you can
play that role that it's not a good
pursuit for your spirit that if you're
not living with virtue and you're not
speaking the truth forward I sound like
I'm reciting Jordan peace but it is and
I think that's one of the reasons why
when I started listening to John
Peterson that it struck such a chord
with me because he told me something
like known all along but it was just
articulated in a way that was to sink to
make sense yeah and it's how he ends his
book says I hope what I've said has
reached the the dreams that you already
knew but said in a way that you maybe
couldn't articulate or something like
that mm-hmm
well if that was that was what it was
and I you know it took a long time of
obviously there's a there's a recoil
effect from that and then processing and
sort and so forth but it was definitely
I think the activation energy that I
needed to be able to think right okay
you can you weren't that person that
means there's a problem problem requires
solution let's find a solution solution
is speak the truth forward and like you
say if I went back on now the person
that I would come across us would be
different so as a good example it wasn't
put into the edit Danielle on the first
night we were that was asking me a
question about something to do with that
she pointed it something I said
something about the tree or the skies or
something like that and I just reeled
off this fact there was something to do
with why it was like that it would have
been like the [ __ ] Coriolis effect
with the earth or something whatever it
was that I knew the answer to and then
she said it like something to do with
tell me some more facts you're really
clever mm-hmm and I remember thinking
there [ __ ] I can't be that person I
can't do the real off the clever facts
partly because I felt a level of anxiety
I was a little bit no I'm just kidding
football pints lads way fancy fancy a
[ __ ] they're gone and but again the
thing is that because I knew that could
play that role as I was sweet right just
do it
just just stick to that because I knew
that was safe ground that got me on the
show so I'm get me through the show mmm
rather than revealing the inner inner
Chris yeah it's a very unusual
conclusion to have come to say like I
spent some time I love Ireland and it
comes people to ensure our Hugo's
authenticity
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not sure how many
do anyone else's have though expiry that
wall-running podcast no I'm just ready
to go yeah I reckon I I hope so run like
you know the guys that are on there the
the people that are on there that do
well are built for that like you looked
at like Chris and cabmen and the guys
that come off from this year you don't
know the LD I do you don't know I do
know so I was I was pretty much
force-fed season three we just on F
Chinese water torture sigh [ __ ] with
my ears but I guess that's the problem
if you don't like it the the sheer
voyage there's so much of it how many I
was 70 or so out too many 69 in the full
casting waiting like well over an hour
now to open the second one I mean you
couldn't do in front of the mic but yeah
no I I don't I'm not sure how many
people saw it as a mindful experience
that catapulted them into living my life
closeted speaking truth and virtue but
the guys that go on there that do well
are already doing that it's just their
truth
mmm-hmm is pretending and us being that
they are being then that being said when
you come out it can be a really
unhealthy environment I think for a lot
of these guys like I know for instance
again because I'm close to Sophie I know
that she's had like a couple of bad
experiences she didn't like the way that
she was portrayed she didn't like the
thing that the media was doing to it one
of the problems is that people going to
come out and the more popular this TV
show gets the deeper and deeper this
sort of stuff's going to get dug and the
more that they want it wouldn't surprise
me if we start to see like Britney
Spears 2007 ask breakdowns from the
glass coming out soon because there's
gonna be someone who goes on likely
through this the psychological yeah
there's gonna be some other fun girls
ones who goes on like me and plays a
role and then wins or gets to the end
and is put on this pedestal and realizes
[ __ ] the game is over but I can't take
the costume off mmm and I think it's
yeah it's it's a it's an interesting one
it's an interesting moment later so if
you approach by press afterwards as well
yeah you get you get bits and parts
again it's my experiences of magnitude
significant magnitude smaller than the
people that are on there now although
going to be on this year and so on and
so forth I wonder if there'll be another
wave now that Netflix is gonna be
running oh I don't know I don't know in
terms of the press because it's not it's
not newsworthy because it's not current
The Situation's are not current Lesley
Chris three years on yeah yeah yeah you
do a catch up but I guess what this is
your day class yes so do you get prep so
far you press free do you get recognized
yeah and more so now again obviously cuz
it's been put back on that flakes well
we were with him when you got recognized
and had to leave the building
oh nice we have to get the bonus that
experience was while waiting for you in
the botanist and suddenly two shots of
tequila arrived bought by someone on the
other side of the bar he was on take me
out with Chris yeah was that he would go
again and then the woman there I was
excuse me she didn't know she didn't
know where if you ever if you have any
an unpleasant I mean that I suppose that
wasn't Pleasant cuz we're to leave well
I left yesterday but as nice as well
it's not it's nice to be a joke and you
drunk
both tequila's just because I had to
yeah yeah but also because they were
free
yeah they were like it was someone's
brought you these oh yeah so is they
were they're free and they're a gift
yeah which means couldn't possibly tell
people about train you won't drink
alcohol so what's better
yeah I'm brilliant not so coming out
thankfully one of the one of the things
I'm really happy about was that because
the way that came across despite being a
intrinsically disingenuous
she came across as an alright guy on
that not this alright guy but they're
different yeah I mean I don't know an
alright guy
and coming out I still - to this day
although this may be asking for trouble
to this day I've yet to have someone
come up to me in the street and say
something that they really really liked
something maybe everyone's just had like
[ __ ] to say oh you are too good for that
Zoe / - nah you know you do you sue do
you still see her do you still you still
in touch and like no like three years on
but there's a scene where you're getting
massages like something's Oh ego is that
when did she say she doesn't like you
she says something to the effect of I
wish this was here it would be fun with
him you just you look up and go okay
well [ __ ] you [ __ ] up yeah okay yeah
hmm I mean again with that like could
you imagine if someone said that to me
now could you imagine this sort of
response that I would give someone who
would say that to me no mm-hmm like
remembering that she was a born-again
Christian they got chlamydia VI six
months before that familiar with the I
am injury in the ER you're like a really
realistic Ajay infection from familiar
in the eye and then got pasted by Jordan
in the toilet downstairs but she's a
born again Christian born-again
Christian I was like this is a girl who
also said the sentence to me I believe
in evolution but I didn't come from no
monkey
very interesting guys thank you so much
for your time it's been a hopefully
people have learned some stuff that they
didn't know about live Island and should
be K by day
good work goodbye then dear mother
[Music]
you